katy perry ariana grande had a one love
unity concert Marley was dead to begin
with it's a unity concert and they went
out and spoke and people are praising
them let's first watch Katy Perry okay
pause isn't she from California it's not
easy to choose love is it yeah it's like
it's not as easy as what I drink my tea
a spot to yeah yeah what a pickpocket
yeah this should let you know that she
has almost no there's nothing of value
to her speech will provide more context
just so you can just for yourself but
right away she's faking an English
accent and no one called her on I've
keep in mind here this concert was
planned before the London this was
Sunday right so this concert was planned
in response to Manchester so after
Manchester well we were offering
concrete solutions and things to do four
steps to be taken moving forward to try
and mitigate the Terrorism problem they
were preparing to offer lip service they
saw the London attack probably from
their hotel suite while they were
preparing for this show so keep that in
context here's Katy Perry's solution or
her from wherever you are back to
America let's just do this little
exercise in love just touch the next
person the next show young girls touch
it
yes the foreign policy and our handling
of terrorists can simply tear a page
from the book of Teddy Ruxpin I love you
even John Mayer's going while we were
actually saving they're talking about
concrete steps won't get to those in a
second they're replace all you need is
love bullcrap concert this unity concert
well here's the thing we'll talk about
unity a second as far as values and
where we can maybe unifying and some
common ground but here's the thing with
unity it doesn't work unless people want
to unify with you what about people out
there Katy Perry if you don't see the
danger in your words what about people
who don't want to what about people who
don't want to unify with your ideas
let's just do this little exercise in
love just touch the next person touch
the person next to you make human
contacts tell them I love you
I encourage you to choose love even when
it's difficult that won't make care okay
unity you wanna really what you mean is
unity under this arbitrary sense of all
you need is love and hand-holding and
kumbaya we are the world but unity one
convenient for your unity if we unify
with your ideals how about we find some
cup how about unity here let me propose
some areas where we can find unity okay
where we can find the unity as a
westernized
freedom loving civilized world against
evil okay I think let's always thinking
about the other person okay Katy Perry
how about no more Sharia Courts in the
UK there are over eighty-five Sharia
Courts in the UK of course on a regular
basis that usurp actual English law and
there's gross atrocities of human rights
violations when you look at women when
you look at the way they treat children
no more Sharia Colette's you gonna find
that right you're a feminist unity get
rid of it tomorrow how about this no
more Imams you deport them any Imam who
comes in the country who promotes Sharia
law who radicalizes anybody as a matter
of fact to the person who radicalized
some of these Islamic terrorists in
Europe recently their video is still
allowed YouTube has decided that it's
still allowed to stay up meanwhile our
criticism of The Young Turks is age
restricted so you define hashtag not all
Muslims let's get rid of the people who
radicalize young Muslims no Imams who
can perform any sort of Sharia law
no Imams who open any mosques were there
Sharia Courts unity how about no more
immigration from countries where they
commit violations of human rights for
women for gays you believe in feminism
you believe in equal rights put the tape
on your mouth
hashtag no hate campaign how about we
don't allow anyone who comes from these
countries who supports the policies and
the laws in place that violate human
rights if you if you come from a country
and you don't renounce everything that
country stood for you don't renounce the
laws including the execution for gays
including the mistreatment of women if
you're coming from
Arabia and you say you know what I'm
kind of iffy on whether women should be
allowed to drive
let's do night we don't want to let them
in right you ready no two-thirds of UK
Muslims but when you talk about just
some radical extremist this is the point
of making wouldn't tell the government
about a terror plot 23 percent openly
admitted wanting full-on Sharia law in
the UK and over fifty percent say
homosexuality should be illegal not gay
shouldn't be able to get Maher married
not maybe gay shouldn't be able to force
bed-and-breakfast or force people to
bake penis cakes the act of being gay
the desire the emotion of one and have
sex with a man should be illegal
hashtag no hate put that scotch tape on
your mouth with Megan McCain as she
grows rotund by the day right let's
unify how about banning the people
anyone who comes into the country who
wants homosexuality period to be illegal
they're not welcome can with unify on
that unify with me and unify with all
the homosexuals are being thrown off
rooftops because they have a risk that
goes like this what if we can't find the
already here where can we find unity
this is my question is it do you really
want unity or you just want to say unity
meaning I want to go out here in a
bleached hair cut put on a fake British
accent and say mr. burns coming out from
the cornfields left us only present
their brand of unity and that's a
problem that's over I can't find unity
on simple lot on a logical floorplan
yeah the fundamentals if you can't agree
on a fundamental I guess sort of
foundation of logic and of principles
and they don't believe that Western
civilization as you see with John Oliver
they can't say that superior as you
talked about huh they can't say well our
ship our culture is superior to the
culture that hangs gays and doesn't
allow women to drive they feel guilty if
they say that so if you can't agree on
some sound logical fundamentals you can
have no unity as a matter of fact you're
much more likely to have unity with the
people who want to chip away at the
foundation of Western civilization which
allows you to write California Gurls and
go up there and lick whipped cream off
your tits and make millions of dollars
Katy Perry
a clip from the full show Daily Show at
lotta with credit calm / mug club or
it's available exclusively 69 dollars a
year that's less than six dollars a
month less than two expensive cups of
coffee or you can feed an African child
but just buy coffee or join the mug club
Daily Show ladder with credit.com / mug
club see you there
don't feed children